hi we are students from st. Louis high
school in Belmar New Jersey we would
like to ask you a question so the
question from the students in st. Rose
school in New Jersey is will the
universe expand forever or will it
collapse well we think that if it
continues to do what it is doing now
that it will expand forever because not
only is it expanding it's accelerating
and going faster and faster all the time
on the other hand since we don't know
why it's doing that we also can't say
that we're sure that it's going to
always do it so other people have a
theory that says well this is something
called membranes coming close together
in a higher dimensional space and that
they can go apart and then come together
so if that were to happen then yes
indeed the universe could collapse again
maybe has been doing this over and over
so I think it's too long a time for us
to ever find out by direct measurement
because the universe has been expanding
for many billions of years and we've
only been here for a short time so we
have to wait too long to find out the
answer to your question I'm sorry